Given a rectangle with length a
squared plus 6a minus 27 and
width a squared minus 9, write
the ratio of the width of the
rectangle to its length as
a simplified rational
expression.
A rational expression is kind
of a fancy word essentially
for a fraction or as a ratio.
They want to us to express the
ratio of the length, so we'll
put the length in the numerator,
to the width.
In the problem, they tell us
that the length right here is
a squared plus 6a minus 27 and
then the width they tell us
right here is a squared
minus 9.
So we've already expressed it as
a rational expression, but
this isn't necessarily
a simplified rational
expression.
Whenever you have any rational
expression-- let me just go
back to what you learned
a long time ago.
If I had something like 2/6,
that's a rational expression,
or that's also a fraction, but
this isn't in the most
simplified form.
What you could do is factor
both of these.
If you do a prime factorization,
it's just 2,
but 6 is 2 times 3.
When you factor them, you see
that you have the same factor
in the numerator and the
denominator, you can cancel
them out, and you can
simplify it to 1/3.
We're going to do the exact
same thing with these
algebraic expressions.
We can factor them and then see
if they have any of the
same terms. If they have the
same terms in the numerator
and the denominator, then we can
cancel them out, and then
we'll just be left with
whatever's left over.
Let's see if we can factor this
numerator right here.
This is going to be equal to--
let me draw the line there.
a squared plus 6a minus 27.
Can we think of two numbers that
if we multiply them, we
get negative 27?
They're going to have to be of
different signs, because when
you multiply them, you get a
negative number, and when you
add them, you get positive 6.
Let's see, 9 minus 3 is 6.
9 times negative 3 is negative
27, so this top expression is
a plus 9 times a minus 3.
We factored it there.
What does this bottom expression
factor into?
This is that standard form, if
you remember, a squared minus
b squared, where in this
case, b would be 3.
b squared would be 9.
We know that this is equal to
a plus b times a minus b.
In this situation, we know this
is a special form that
would be factored into a
plus 3 times a minus 3.
We see there is a term that is
common to both the numerator
and the denominator:
a minus 3.
You have a minus 3 in the
numerator and you have an a
minus 3 in the denominator.
So we can divide the numerator
and the denominator by a minus
3, or that they would
cancel out.
a minus 3 divided by a minus
3, assuming that a is not
equal to 3, because then it
would become undefined, but if
we assume a does not equal to 3,
something divided by itself
will just be 1.
Then we'll just be left with
a plus 9 over a plus 3, and
that's about as simplified as
we can get for this rational
expression.